[Música]
quando me convidaram pra ver pede que eu
fiz uma pergunta eterna desculpa eu
estou me curando de uma gripe também
conhecida
fiz uma pergunta interna mas porque me
convidaram pra sair no ted o que eu
posso falar que pode ser interessante
pra alguém né
e aí eu comecei a fazer uma regressão
lúcida é da minha história assim e ele
vem uma imagem que sempre me incomodou
durante muito tempo que quando chego em
um hotel e eu preciso preencher a ficha
do hotel e na ficha do hotel tem uma
pergunta profissão
eu nunca soube responder a uma pergunta
e eu nunca soube responder àquela
pergunta por que eu tenho dúvidas do que
é a minha profissão o que eu exerço
realmente com a minha função dentro da
sociedade o que o que eu estou sendo
programado para né
e essa pergunta sempre ficou comigo e eu
venho tentando preencher essa lacuna
durante vinte e tantos anos né
hoje eu tenho um pouco de clareza e eu
entendo que é uma profissão é a soma dos
seus conhecimentos e você pode dizer
cela de inúmeras maneiras
você pode se formar na universidade de
vivências oferece suficientes para poder
levantar e construir uma casa para
alguém isso é uma profissão é a soma dos
seus conhecimentos
mas como que você adquire esses
conhecimentos durante a sua trajetória
como que você soma eles pra você como
que eles entram dentro de você pra mim
são com duas respostas muito simples sim
ou não a todo momento da nossa vida a
gente tem uma decisão para tomar a toda
hora a todo instante a gente precisa
tomar uma decisão e as decisões da nossa
vida são muito simples são baseadas
nessas duas respostas
nada mais não tem talvez não tenham vou
pensar
no final você precisa responder sim ou
não à então as decisões são muito mais
simples do que a gente pensa
e aí pensando nessas decisões que me
trouxeram até aqui
eu tentei lembrar de algumas importantes
que realmente me transformaram lembro do
momento com sete anos quando tive uma
briga na escola que eu apanhei um cara
quer o dobro do meu tamanho mas que
naquele momento eu tive que decidir sim
ou não enfrenta ou não eu enfrentei
apanhei e veio uma resposta clara para
essas decisões
elas trazem conseqüências certo não
muito boas naquele momento mas ficou
claro pra mim que toda decisão que a
gente toma tem uma conseqüência
quando eu tinha 14 anos começou um
processo que a denise falou aqui que é o
que você vai ser o que você vai estudar
na universidade você vai fazer o que
você quer ser quando você crescer e essa
pergunta fica por muito tempo inclusive
nas fichas de hotel até hoje as pessoas
pergunta pra você qual a sua profissão o
que você faz dentro dessa sociedade
porque é um julgamento é uma cobrança
fica a critério de cada um
quando eu tinha 14 anos então eu decidi
que eu queria ser técnico agrícola e
essa decisão foi minha de mais ninguém
eu disse sim eu quero ser técnico
agrícola
eu estudei entrei num colégio interno na
época o colégio é só admitirá homens né
entrei no colégio interno em balneário
em camboriú na verdade
e aí eu fiquei um ano trabalhando todos
os dias de manhã estudando e à tarde
roçando carpindo é dirigindo tratores
lidando com gado de leite com gado de
corte e plantio trabalho que dava cabo
nas mãos e isso foi uma parte do
conhecimento que eu adquirir bom esse
período que eu entrei no colégio
agrícola e eu fiquei um ano dentro de si
colégio trabalhando foi um período que
me trouxe muito conhecimento
conhecimento que uso até hoje
todo esse conhecimento continua comigo
nesse momento depois de um ano decidi
que aquilo não era a profissão para mim
não era o que eu queria e naquele
momento que eu decidi que não era o que
eu queria eu entrei em contato com meu
pai e falei pra ele olha pai voltar aqui
o momento tiquinho né
lá estou eu e vocês devem saber por que
o tiquinho o menorzinho de todos e mais
magrinha
foi um ano ali eu liguei pro meu pai
disse olha eu não quero mais estudar no
colégio agrícola acho que isso não é pra
mim não é o que eu quero
e naquele momento o meu pai disse não
você vai ficar até o final
você vai terminar o colégio agrícola
você vai até o final eu voltei para o
quarto dormir com mais 17 meninos
deitei na minha câmera bilich e naquela
noite eu disse não eu não vou ficar
essa decisão é minha não é dele
as decisões somos nós que tomamos
se a gente quer traçar uma meta na nossa
vida se a gente quer trilhar o nosso
próprio caminho
ninguém pode tomar a decisão por nós
infelizmente não tinha poder suficiente
para pegar minhas coisas e ir embora
para casa e dizer sim estou aqui não vou
mais
eu tracei um plano de como sair do
colégio agrícola
esse plano não foi um plano muito
inteligente eu confesso mas eu tracei
ele eu roubei o trator
eu fui até balneário camboriú
passei uma noitada com alguns amigos e
voltamos para o colégio
após isso claro que eu não estava mais
no colégio né
eu fui expulso do colégio agrícola e
essa nesse momento o sim eo não me
trouxeram outra informação além da
conseqüência tem a responsabilidade e
quando você decide por sim ou não em
alguma coisa você tem que estar ciente
que vem uma consequência e que você tem
que assumir as responsabilidades
tá bom cheguei em casa
óbvio que me perguntaram e agora o que
você vai fazer a pergunta que até hoje
fazem pra gente eu disse bom não sei vou
continuar o segundo grau ou tentar uma
faculdade alguma coisa nessa época eu
peguei uma cã
aprendi a usar aprendi a fotografar
enquadrar a enxergar e eu via o mundo
que eu queria ver dentro de quatro
linhas mas tudo bem isso não é coisa de
alguém que quer ser alguém na vida né
vamos lá entrei na agronomia acreditei
que eu seria um agrônomo que o período
do colégio agrícola foi apenas uma
besteira da minha cabeça e fui pra
agronomia
eu fiz dois anos a economia passa em
duas matérias sensacional
uma porque o professor passava todo
mundo ea outra porque a carolina que é
uma colega nossa meu colo na última
prova
então essa foi a minha história da
economia mas não tem uma história por
trás disso que foi a convivência dentro
de uma universidade que a universidade
federal do paraná
esse período de não ir para a aula de
estar com os amigos de sair de conviver
e de estudar de ajudar os outros a
estudarem de estar junto de estar
conectado que me fizeram muito bem e que
talvez tenham feito o melhor período de
formação da minha vida
foram esses dois anos que eu passei em
duas matérias
bom eu sair eu liguei para o meu pai e
disse eu não quero mais fazer economia
disse ben a correndo pra casa
o apronto mais nenhuma por aí né eu vim
correndo pra casa e meu pai colocou me
colocou no comércio mais uma tentativa
de ter uma profissão afinal de contas
você precisa fazer alguma coisa eu
fiquei no comércio durante um ano
continuava brincando com a fotografia e
nessa brincadeira uma produtora de vídeo
me chamou e disse vem a estagiar comigo
é e eu entrei nessa produtora dentro
dessa produtora eu descobri que existia
uma profissão que se enquadrava no que
eu estava que era a direção de
fotografia é não fazer o clic igual né
a direção de fotografia e quando decide
se é o diretor de fotografia e
eram as consequências das
responsabilidades que é você dizer que o
pai eu não vou mais cedo comércio vou
fazer uma profissão que ele nem sabe até
hoje que é direito e você tem que ter a
responsabilidade de assumir isso e tocar
sua vida pra frente
fui e sou ainda o diretor de fotografia
até hoje
comecei muito mais com isso e todo esse
conhecimento que eu vinha adquirindo até
o momento de virar um diretor de
fotografia sempre foram úteis para mim
nunca nada ficou para trás
nunca eu disse ah não precisava aprender
isso tempo perdido fazer isso nunca toda
a informação que vem e que eu tenho até
hoje são importantes durante esse
período da direção de fotografia um
amigo me chamou para fotografar um
catálogo para ele essa é a que estamos
num pólo de moda e ele me disse 'não
você fotografa pra eu filmar
ok e aí por mágica eu virei um fotógrafo
que é uma das profissões que eu também
exerce até hoje eu fotografei moda e
fotografia ainda durante um bom tempo e
essa profissão me possibilitou viajar
para inúmeros lugares fotografar
mulheres muito bonitas e eu acho que só
isso já valeu a pena
minha esposa está andando muito feliz
mas ele fique bom nessa jornada toda
muita gente pergunta para você o que
você faz
eu sou fotógrafa você faz batizado não
casamento não há então o que você faz
faço o fotográfo moda moda você trabalha
para revistas não o que você faz o
diretor de fotografia o que é isso aí o
trabalho junto com o diretor em filmes
em mim filme publicitário era sempre
muito difícil explicar o que eu fazia e
continua sendo até hoje
e nesse processo todo disse poxa eu
preciso fazer alguma coisa mais e eu
criei uma empresa porque eu vivi aqui em
criciúma trabalhava no mundo cria uma
empresa
chamada black box a black box é a maior
locadora de equipamentos de cinema do
sul do país atende hoje o brasil inteiro
tem cinco longas metragens na na sua no
seu currículo mais de 300 comerciais
nacionais e internacionais entre itaú
volkswagen fox inúmeros comerciais é
gigantescos vamos dizer assim com
equipes de 300 pessoas é que dias de
filmagens e a black box fornece
equipamentos para esse tipo de trabalho
então eu passei a seu empresário também
as pessoas perguntam qual a sua
profissão sou empresário entregará o que
você tem é difícil e eu continuo não
sabendo que preencher e nessa minha
busca por saber o que preencher o que me
o que me move o que me traz até aqui e
cheio de dúvidas na cabeça há um mês
atrás exatamente no meu aniversário eu
peguei a minha avó paterna ele veio
visitar minha avó materna
a minha avó paterna tem 90 anos a minha
avó materna tem quase 90 anos
eu disse poxa gente corre a vida inteira
procurando alguma coisa né querendo
responder alguma coisa querendo
responder a ficha do hotel eu vou
perguntar pra elas
elas têm experiência né e aí eu
perguntei pra uma das minhas avós
perguntei para as duas na verdade qual é
a lição que a senhora leva da vida
são muitas delas
olha eu acho tinha eu aprendi tudo eu
acredito em tudo e ouvindo as minhas
avós responder tristeza e eu aprendi
tudo eu voltei lá pro início da minha e
do meu raciocínio
a vida é muito simples é sim e não tá na
tua mão a decisão está na tua mão
aprender dessa vida levar alguma coisa
dessa vida uma bagagem boa ou levar
tristeza está na nossa mão de mais
ninguém nós tomamos a decisão que eu
tomei a decisão de vender essa minha
empresa no auge do sucesso dela black
box logo depois dessa viagem faz três
semanas que eu vendia empresa e agora eu
sei o que o preço na ficha do hotel
porque a vida é um aprendizado
cada um leva o que acho que quer e eu
decidi levar disso a lição das minhas
duas avós e hoje eu preencho
desempregado com muito orgulho e é muito
mais fácil que ninguém faz perguntas
também não tem medo de correr atrás do
que você quer faz de você um realizador
eu acho que eu durante 20 anos
tenho tentado realizar o que tem dentro
de mim
obrigado